[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu sein wir sind
seit gestern macht wieder zurück aus dem
urlaub wir waren um halb eins mehrheit 2
waren wir im bett und heute morgen stand
ich schon um 8 uhr auf der baustelle
samira und erlasse mit dabei weil meine
eltern auch gerade noch in der türkei
sind in urlaub machen aber das kriegen
wir alles sind baustellen update gibt es
demnächst ich möchte euch heute aber
sagen dass sich am 19
auf der ifa bin das ist ein samstag und
die ifa in berlin das ist die
internationale funkausstellung das ist
eine richtig coole messe letztes jahr
war ich ja auch bereits bei porsche auf
dem stand und habe euch dort die
neuesten neuigkeiten gezeigt und
technischen highlights auch dieses jahr
zeige ich euch dann in einem video
wieder alles was es neues gibt und ich
kann euch sagen es wird richtig schick
also ich habe schon ein paar sachen
gehört und gesehen und matt habe ich
heute noch nicht dazu verraten aber ihr
könnt euch entweder live auf der ifa
anschauen oder dann einfach im video
update verläuft dann wieder so ab dass
ich drei mal für euch kochen und backen
werde also ich bin wirklich von morgens
bis abends den ganzen tag da fotos
können wir zusammen machen autogramme
kann ich geben ihr könnt doch gerne eure
bücher und schützen mitnehmen und ich
kann die auch gerne für euch zitierte
schon ziemlich viel spaß im hintergrund
kindergarten es leider nicht schulferien
haben wir auch gerade noch deswegen
müssen wir jetzt noch die sommerferien
überbrücken
ihr könnt gerne karten gewinnen für die
ifa und zwar verlose ich 25 x 2 tickets
für euch und ihr könnt einfach an diese
e mail adresse schreiben und wenn ihr
sie gewonnen habt dann bekommt ihr eine
e mail zurück mit den zugangsdaten und
mit den ticket daten und ansonsten falls
sie die karten nicht gewinnt könnt ihr
sie natürlich auch im vorverkauf holen
entweder online auf der seite der ifa
oder auch direkt vor ort also wenn ihr
am ersten neun kommt könnte auch vor ort
die tickets holen aber im vorverkauf da
sind halt immer so ein bisschen
günstiger und da gibt's sogar
kombiticket also dass ihr auch praktisch
bahntickets und so weiter mit dabei habt
da könnte einfach mal reinschauen und
ich würde mich wirklich sehr sehr freuen
wenn ihr dabei seid murat ist auch mit
dabei er darf auch mit mir ein bisschen
kochen und backen und ihr dürft alles
kostenlos probieren also kommt vorbei
dann können wir uns unterhalten und ihr
könnt mir fragen stellen ich beantworte
sie gerne murat ist auch da vielleicht
macht er sogar morath fünf minuten
vielleicht kann ich ihnen dazu überreden
wir gucken mal also ich würde nicht
wirklich sehr freuen wenn ihr dabei seid
am 1
die in berlin es gibt dieses jahr noch
weitere termine von mir ich werde auch
mal glaube ich in leipzig sein
aber da bekommt ihr die termine noch
mitgeteilt aber für dieses jahr ist es
einfach die letzte messe also wenn ihr
dieses jahr noch mal was von mir
probieren wollte kuchen oder auch was
herzhaftes dann kommt gerne auf die
messe nach berlin auf die ifa und die
ist wirklich toll also der können eure
männer mitnehmen sie werden begeistert
sein
eure frauen können damit nehmen die
kinder haben auch ganz viel zu entdecken
und zu erleben und ich glaube das ist
auch wirklich was für die ganze familie
wir werden jetzt nach hause gehen müssen
noch wäsche waschen die ganze urlaub
special steht noch an
und wie gesagt ich freue mich wenn ihr
vorbeikommt auf die ifa am ersten
neunten und ja was kann man noch sagen
wünsche euch noch einen schönen tag
genießen nach unseren tag diamanten
roloff genau wir haben baustelle murat
ist gerade auf der baustelle muss
aufräumen gerüst abbauen
alles weg bringen wegfahren und wir
räumen jetzt zu hause auf und gehen dann
noch ein bisschen raus okay also bis
bald und meine videos gibt's übrigens
wieder im september ich habe im august
ein bisschen urlaub also chemmy alcott
ich werde ich werde 30
darf ich das euch sagen ich komme noch
nicht klar damit alles schlimm bin ich
eine alte mama
[Musik]
diana du bist die königin elsa
karaoke-show deluxe aber nicht das
mikrofon anfangs einfach dran hängen und
dann ganz zum turm gucken und dann okay
[Musik]